yeah yeah it's it's nice saying and and
good guidelines I guess ultimately
that's what every religion I guess has
to as a goal is to inspire its followers
to do what's what's best and and do the
right thing so I think somewhere in
there they all kind of connect going for
the same thing it's nice it's
Grandmaster H and Gracie again really
nice to reunite with you and have you on
the program and again the book now very
important self-defense being able to
defend yourself you find yourself such a
vulnerable situation like you saw the
Father and Son the guy knocks both of
them out you know and the antidote for
that is getting educated